all right welcome to hannity for the
full hour by the way our coverage of the
fbi's alarming raid at mar-a-lago we're
going to go into specific details that i
promise you won't get from the
mainstream media we'll go through it
slowly we'll check in with senator marco
rubio paul manafort he went through a
pre-dawn raid uh guns drawn no knock uh
john solomon the great one mark levine
will all join us live tonight and here
now more than 24 hours have passed and
scores of heavily armed fbi agents
stormed into president trump's private
home at mar-a-lago in palm beach
unannounced for their raid this is
totally unprecedented it should be
deeply deeply concerning to every
american citizen it should transcend
politics not only is president trump a
former u.s president he is also biden's
chief political rival so naturally the
white house is very short tonight on
answers take a
look on a different topic the fbi is a
certain search warrant on the former
president's residence in florida
was the president or anyone at the white
house aware of that search warrant or
had has anyone at the white house or the
president been briefed in the aftermath
of that search warrant being executed no
the president was not brief did not was
not aware of it no no one at the white
house was given a heads up no that did
not happen
all right let me be extremely clear as
someone
who's one of the loudest supporters if
you've watched this show or listen to my
radio show of law enforcement on tv and
radio in the country for decades
after years of witch hunts political
persecutions the russia hoax frankly our
department of justice our fbi's
reputation is already in tatters
especially with anything related to
donald trump and now this especially
biden's fbi and doj that have had hunter
biden's laptop for years a laptop that
implicates both hunter and joe biden the
big guy himself in numerous crimes and
lies and they have not lifted a finger
at the fbi or the doj to bring justice
to the biden family frankly
unfortunately i say this i no longer
believe that in this great country of
ours that we have equal justice under
the law nor do i believe we have equal
application of our laws in this country
if your last name is clinton or biden
you likely get a pass if your last name
is trump or if you are an associate with
anything trump you get the heavy-handed
tactics of pre-dawn raids guns drawn and
in some cases even fake news cnn cameras
again let me be very clear i used to
always say on this program during the
russia hoax 99 rank and file fbi agents
put their lives at risk work hard to
keep this country safe tonight i say
it's about 95 percent there are a lot of
good people in the fbi and in law
enforcement and in the intelligence
community the fbi and the doj they have
sadly earned the country's distrust
especially the upper echelon which we
now know has been and continues to
remain
rotten to the core
now this raid wreaks a political bias
and intimidation yet total silence from
christopher wray at the fbi total
silence from merrick garland at the
department of justice apparently they
answer to nobody least of all you the
american people why was this raid
conducted americans deserve answers
tonight even mitch mcconnell is asking
for them and by the way jim jordan wants
answers on friday director ray and
merrick garland ought to go before
congress according to reports the fbi
was looking for presidential records
requested by the national archives from
trump's time in the white house uh well
call me a skeptic i don't buy that for
one second this likely does not have
much if anything to do with the national
archives well you don't raid the
president's home
before dawn with dozens of agents for a
few documents that may or may not belong
to the national archives in a statement
from february the national archives said
that they obtained quote full
cooperation from trump officials and
were already working with them to
transfer key documents the fbi agents on
the scene reportedly took every document
in sight at mar-a-lago without even
bothering to read any of the material
and according to eric trump on the show
last night and numerous other sources
that we have on this program the fbi
refused to allow the president's
attorneys to watch what they took why
not and it gets worse the judge who
reportedly signed off on the warrant big
obama donor by the way and once
represented jeffrey epstein's employees
as their attorney i'm sure he's a man of
great character obviously this was a
fishing expedition in search of
something anything and now we're finding
out that a trump ally congressman scott
perry he just had his phone seized by
the fbi earlier today again no
explanation whatsoever we'll have more
on this in a moment after all the doj
and the fbi lies and all their
conspiracy theories their three-year
plus-long hoax including the fbi
insurance policy of peter strzok they
have now earned the loss of trust for we
you we the american people the deep
state sadly is alive and well in this
country and we are now witnessing a dark
new chapter into the persecution of
donald trump and sadly the weaponization
of our department of justice now you may
ask why would anyone who's a republican
and conservative trust the biden fbi and
the biden doj first they tried remember
this same fbi department of justice same
same institutional people they tried to
make a connection between trump tower
and the alpha bank a major russia uh
institutional uh financial institution
and that the servers were inside a trump
tower it was a bogus story it's been
totally debunked then they moved on to
the fake claims from the dirty russian
dossier that was the collection of
russian disinformation bought and paid
for by hillary clinton shut donald
trump's opponent in 2016 in the dnc
none of the claims in that dossier were
verified or even verifiable they've been
debunked but that didn't stop the fbi
the top echelon from using that phony
material not once not twice but four
times as evidence and four separate fisa
applications against trump uh campaign
ad carter page they used the warrant by
lying to the fisa court even when the
sub source of christopher steele said uh
none of it's true and they used it to
back door into the trump campaign to spy
and then of course
spy on them president trump and the
trump transition team and the trump
presidency can you imagine that and of
course the media mob their allies they
lied to you the american people for over
three long years everything we were
reported has been vindicated this led to
the mueller probe that led to a two-year
witch hunt that ultimately found nothing
despite a non-stop legal barrage against
nearly everyone in trump world now
former campaign manager paul manafort
remember he faced a pre-dawn raid guns
pointed in his face his wife's face
followed by numerous financial charges
dating back to his time as a consultant
he spent weeks and weeks and months in
solitary confinement he was paraded
around in shackles like a serial killer
he will join us tonight roger stone he
endured a pre-dawn raid the fbi even put
fbi frogmen in the water behind stone's
house and someone invited fake news cnn
cameras to film it all at 5 30 a.m and
meanwhile you know what happened to
lieutenant general flynn his family was
treated with legal charges before that
and flynn was purposely misled by yep
director james comey himself he wanted
to take advantage i sent them of trump's
new administration the first few days
when he was in office and george
papadopoulos railroaded with a process
crime more recently peter navarro
handcuffed shackled at an airport
publicly humiliated because of a
misdemeanor usually tell somebody to
report at this time or we will send
people out and execute a warrant hillary
clinton put america's national security
at risk by storing classified material
on her private server do we have equal
justice in this country she tried to
cover it up we know by destroying
evidence including wiping hard drives
with something we never knew or heard
about before called bleach bit she
destroyed phones with hammers she
returned other phones without the sim
cards meaning without anything in them
she deleted over 30 000 official emails
and at the height of that investigation
into these emails hillary's husband bill
was having a strange conversation with
obama's attorney general loretta lynch
during a private meeting on a tarmac of
an airport in arizona naturally after
the state department report found 500
violations surrounding this private
server scandal hillary was never charged
with a crime her home was never raided
hunter biden also encountered a pre-dawn
raid oh that's right that never happened
he's not to face any charges also the
president's son was filmed himself
smoking crack on multiple occasions
that's against the law there's a
mountain of evidence that he frequently
hired prostitutes including those
trafficked from overseas he also lied on
a gun application he lost track of that
handgun that ended up in a dumpster near
a school at the same time hunter raked
in millions and millions and millions of
dollars from foreign nationals and
countries for no apparent reason other
than access to his father's position as
vice president government hunter took 4
million from ukrainian oil gas giant and
gas giant barisma he took three and a
half million dollars from the former
first lady of moscow he took part of a
multi-billion dollar sweetheart
sweetheart deal with the bank of china
1.5 billion he had a hundred thousand
dollar family shopping spree compliments
of a chinese communist party official
and this is just the tip of the iceberg
where's that raid and all told joe biden
in spite of what he said publicly he met
at least 14 of hunter's international
business partners i never one time
discuss with my son any of his foreign
business dealings now many of those
encounters will photograph but for some
reason joe denied ever discussing
business with hunter he lied to you the
american people and we have evidence of
that lie and by the way it's all on
hunter's laptop which is not russian
disinformation and uh director ray and
the fbi have had it longer than anybody
and nothing has happened peter navarro
shackled at an airport for a misdemeanor
roger stone gets his house rated for a
process crime hunter biden can
apparently do anything he wants and
he'll get away with it and as for those
national archive records that suddenly
triggered the raid at mar-a-lago here's
how you know it's complete and total bs
one former top aide for bill clinton
named sandy berger remember sandy the
burglar yeah he tried to steal and did
steal classified material
about 911 right from the national
archives in other words he went into the
national archives found the documents he
was looking for shoved him down his
pants on his backside into his socks and
walked out and sandy burger was punished
with a mere slap on the wrist a
misdemeanor and a fine and everybody in
the media mob and democrats they just he
was just being sloppy he was sloppy
sloppy sloppy took the he didn't mean to
take him when he threw it right down his
crotch he didn't mean that at all
he had no idea that was classified
material that made his way into his
underwear a former president of the
united states gets a pre-dawn raid does
any of this seem normal to you on top of
three years of russia conspiracy lies
hoaxes misinformation propaganda
and
an abuse of power and corruption like
we've never seen in history before on
twitter house leader mccarthy told
merrick garland to quote preserve your
documents and clear your calendar for an
investigation into the weaponization of
the department of justice florida
governor ron desantis compared the fbi's
actions to something that happens in a
banana republic virginia governor
younkin said that these kinds of
politically motivated actions have no
place in our democracy even democrat
former governor of new york andrew cuomo
declaring the doj must immediately
explain the reason for this raid and it
must be more than a search for
inconsequential archives or it will be
viewed as a political tactic and
undermine any future credible
investigation that credibility to me has
been long gone the credibility of the
fbi and the doj
was always hanging by a thread merrick
garland chris wray they remain silent
and that silence tonight is deafening
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else